Jo.
Takže přecházíme k bitům
a qubit budou základní výpočetní stavební kameny
se kterými můžeme řešit
složité problémy světa
takže se pokusme pochopit rozdíl mezi nimi
a odkud pramení síla qubit
podíváme-li se na levou stranu
je to způsob, jak to popsat, a budeme tyhle diagramy používat
v celé prezentaci, abychom
ukázali tu sílu – vidíme kruh
a dvě tečky, když je tečka na severním pólu
je to nula, když je na jižním pólu, je to jednička
to je klasický bit se dvěma stavy, qubit je
jednotka informace v kvantovém světě
a tady máme co do činění s obrázkem
jako sféra pro nulu i jedničku
a můžeme je mít v tomhle stavu superpozice
máme k dispozici speciální trik
nejenže je můžeme umístit do libovolné polohy na sféře
ale představ si, že každý z nich
je jako malý Měsíc
který je na té sféře a my ho můžeme otáčet
takže tady vidíš, že
spodní sféra byla trochu otočena
proto vidíš trochu modré
a růžové, a mohli bychom to otočit úplně
tady je posun o sto osmdesát stupňů
takže máme tenhle pojem fáze, který nám kvantový svět nabízí
tři superschopnosti, které se projevují u qubit
jsou to schopnosti superpozice
schopnost interference
a schopnost provázanosti
pojďme si je projít – princip superpozice je vlastně
docela snadné pochopit
takže hvězda na levé straně
je buď nula na severním pólu, nebo jednička na jižním pólu
a když tyto dva stavy sečteme
dostaneme qubit v superpozici, který má zároveň
nulu i jedničku současně na severu
i na jihu, pravý diagram je stejný
ale teď uděláme malý trik
použijeme gate, kvantový gate
to, co jsme udělali tady, pamatuj si
teď to můžeme změnit, teď můžeme
otáčet ty malé Měsíce, jo
takže jsme ho otočili o sto
osmdesát stupňů a teď máme jedničku
takže teď, když uděláme součet nuly a jedničky, skončíme
se stavem superpozice
ale všimni si, že je jiný
ten vlevo – tam máme
pořád nulu i jedničku, ale teď s otočeným stavem
pro jedničku, a to bude velmi silné
pro využití druhé opravdu zajímavé věci, kterou je
princip interference
a to je operace, kterou v klasickém
bitovém světě provádět nemůžeme, takže tady v tomhle příkladu máme
nulu i jedničku vlevo plus
tento nový stav, který jsme vytvořili
což je také nula i jednička
ale s tímto otočeným Měsícem, když to teď uděláme
tyto dva stavy se mohou interferovat
a všimni si, že se stalo něco opravdu zajímavého
zrušili jsme stav jedničky
a skončili jsme se stavem nuly
udělali jsme to tím, že jsme nechali ty stavy interferovat
takže další příležitost, kterou teď máme
je kolik stavů můžeme vytvořit
a krásná věc v kvantovém světě je, že můžeme vytvořit exponenciální
počet stavů, takže se podívejme na systém, který má
pět qubit – v tomhle případě zobrazujeme tyto qubit
jako nezávislé qubit, vidíš je vlevo
nuly a jedničky, které se násobí, máme jich pět
takže počet stavů, které můžeme vytvořit ve
kvantovém počítači zobrazeném na sféře vpravo
je dvě na
mocninu počtu qubit, které máme, v tomhle případě pět
takže dvě na pátou jsou třicet dva stavů
vidíme tedy těch třicet dva malých Měsíců
všimni si, že v tomhle případě jsme nezahrnuli
žádnou fázi – všechny jsou růžové, silná stránka
využití této vlastnosti zvané provázanost v kvantovém světě
spočívá v tom, že teď můžeme vytvářet stavy
jako ten zobrazený vpravo
kde máme tyto kombinace růžové
a modré, přičemž tento stav nelze popsat
jako nezávislý součin
těchto pěti qubit, v tomhle případě
jelikož máme třicet dva stavů
to nám říká něco velmi hlubokého